President Trump and the former FBI
director have a complicated history it
goes back to mr. Trump's presidential
campaign against Hillary Clinton when he
went back and forth praising and
criticizing James Comey well that
pattern continued when he entered the
White House Jeff pjs looks back at what
the president said and did about Comey
Jeff good morning good morning during
the campaign President Trump was
critical of former FBI director Comey
when he announced in July that Hillary
Clinton should not face charges in
connection with the investigation into a
private email server but then candidate
Trump turned criticism to praise when
Comey announced just before the election
that the investigation had been reopened
one day after commis announcement at a
campaign rally in Arizona then candidate
Trump was singing his praises I respect
the fact that director Comey was able to
come back after what he did I respect
that but a month after he was sworn in
Trump blasted commis FBI on Twitter
saying the FBI is totally unable to stop
the National Security leakers adding
they can't even find the leakers within
the FBI itself those tweets were in
response to leaked media reports
claiming the White House asked the FBI
to debunk claims that members of Trump's
campaign had been in contact with Russia
then in mid-march Comey confirmed that
the FBI was investigating Russian
meddling in the 2016 election and that
includes investigating the nature of any
links between individuals associated
with the Trump campaign and the Russian
government by early May Trump was
targeting Comey on Twitter saying FBI
director Comey was the best thing that
ever happened to Hillary Clinton in that
he gave her a free pass for many bad
deeds
a week later President Trump suddenly
fired Comey while he was visiting an FBI
office in Los Angeles Thank You mr.
Trump originally said that he was acting
based on a memo from Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein that was critical
of commis handling of the Clinton email
investigation but that explanation later
changed the president over the last
several months
lost confidence in director Comey and
frankly he'd been considering letting
director Comey go since the day he was
elected and it was the timing of the
firing that raised alarms here in
Washington the FBI was in the midst of
the rush investigation and Comey had
those memos of his private conversations
with the president the drumbeat of calls
for commis testimony grew louder Charlie
Jeff thanks